premium execution is the calling card
for Tony Bennett's Cavaliers cow god he
has really struggled in this tournament
and that's a good sign for him early
tile guy gets his first jumper Kyle guy
averaging 15 plus points per game he is
a light and find themselves with another
chance to advance to the Elite Eight
tied to Rome country
Oh God the racket up he's old for three
a mean for three got it home because of
the penetration of Pritchard that's the
second one right there's one key you
don't want that one
from their diminutive the guard key hey
Clark the freshmen
Richardson tips it up throw it down
Kenny Williams face the beautiful play
by Richardson the past gives it up drunk
inside DJ is one
hoping for a travel on this play let's
see no he kept his pivot foot down the
nice strong print hunter little floater
no taps it to Clark another chance great
Pat's notebook and the two-handed Jam do
'quite a beautiful basketball by
Virginia key hey Clark
[Applause]
beautiful my key hey Clark what coral
was the key to Oregon's turnaround
according to Dana all but he was the one
guy that was playing selfless basketball
selling off his teammates finally hits a
three are not Oregon with a little more
on since the urgency and energy
last touch by to roll a car did not by
dear Keaton the mean who hit a couple of
big threes in the first half
you had that technical foul he's got
three fouls now and so said this is a
one point game keep it going
get after the ball be the more
aggressive team DJ pens one on the
backboard here comes the helping if he
would've known he could have thrown the
hoop to Wooten Everton dear Kate a
pinning it against the backboard
I kind of get him pushing into the
pick-and-roll now he can become a
playmaker and he just doesn't have the
trip shot clock at two and here is K
[Applause]
just says the timer was expiring hold it
and it's gone the other way
Luis Cage buries the triple and gives
Oregon the lead
look at the person Prichard is putting
on a tongue they started to go out of
the last couple of plays and bang Jerome
says yeah you can check me all you want
I can still knock down the shop they
have been the hot team once they got
their pieces back and healthy here is
king Mary's another three for Oregon
Jerome with Prichard honor and here's
key hey Clark from the double fist what
that means is man-to-man switching
everything now they could change it but
right now us with their really first 255
wins here is Jerome now into the hands
of Jerome that's who they want a guy got
great ball handlers out here it's a
possession game neither team should be
ashamed of their effort even though it
hurts to lose key hey Clark
we do it the Virginia Cavaliers are
moving on to the Elite Eight